[Music]
you
[Music]
if you have heart failure your heart has
lost the ability to pump enough blood to
meet your body's needs
you may have weak or damaged ventricular
walls that are not able to push enough
blood out of your heart
you may also have stiff and thickened
ventricular walls that do not allow your
heart to fill with enough blood
if you have left-sided heart failure
your left ventricle does not deliver
enough oxygen-rich blood to your body
making you feel tired and out of breath
you're failing left ventricle also
increases the blood pressure in the
blood vessels between your lungs and
left ventricle
this increased pressure forces fluid out
of your blood and into your lung tissues
which makes it difficult for you to
breathe
if you have right-sided heart failure
your right ventricle is unable to
contract with enough force to push blood
to your lungs
the result is a buildup of blood in your
veins
which causes a buildup of fluid called
edema throughout the tissues in your
body
over time heart failure on either side
of your heart results in weakened
enlarged ventricles that deliver less
blood to your body
to make up for the decreased amount of
blood your nervous system releases
stress hormones that increase the speed
and force of your heartbeat
unfortunately the continued release of
these stress hormones makes your heart
failure worse because they damage the
muscle cells in your ventricles